dans les antilles néerlandaises
la petite île volcanique de sapins 13
kilomètres carrés n'était pas vraiment
fait pour accueillir l'homme et pourtant
il est là niché dans les moindres
recoins que la nature a bien voulu lui
laisser les installations humaines se
sont tant bien que mal accroché un
plateau et au valais
les falaises abruptes cerny et accentue
encore son isolement
les allemands à son charme mais l'être
humain ne peut se passer longtemps de
communication par chance la nature
imprévu au nord-est du bloc volcanique
une toute petite surface plane on ya
installé deux pistes d'atterrissage qui
tient plus du porte avions que de
l'amour